hey there and welcome to pro flows
number 44 I'm Cameron and let's take a
look at what I'm gonna show you here
today so right here I've got some
footage and let's say that you are
required to possibly change maybe just
this top line here okay so you want to
apply some effects you have to you've
colorize it make it maybe a green or
blue and it needs to have a little bit
of the glow how do you go about doing
that in easy in the most straightforward
way let me show you how you do that it's
really simple so we're gonna start with
just applying some hue and saturation
and we're going to colorize this footage
so there we go
we're going to let's make it
I don't know maybe somewhere right here
and let's also just boost that
saturation way up so we can really see
it okay and let's also apply a little
bit of a glow effect so let's go down to
stylize glow and let's just play around
a little bit let's just bump the radius
way up there something like that and
then we're gonna take the intensity way
down to maybe like 0.3 so it's just a
very nice subtle glow there so that's
with the glow and without and now here
comes the magic let's just apply this
effect these two effects just to this
area right here so how do we do that we
just draw a mask that's all we have to
do is we're going to take that mask pen
tool draw mask
there we go and we're going to turn hit
f4 feather and we're going to feather
this way up to something like 150 pixels
there we go and here comes the real
magic let's just scroll this down let's
open up effects go to the first one hue
and saturation and here is where the
magic happens we can see there's a
little box here called compositing
options with the checkmark okay and
there's nothing inside of here except
for a effect opacity but as soon as we
hit + boom there's our mask and it's
only affecting what's inside of this
mask now we need to apply this the glow
as well as you can see the glow is still
happening to the entire image so that's
without and with so let's open up glow
go down to compositing options hit + and
boom it's only applied to this area
inside of here now
so if I go and I turn effects off on off
on you can see it's only being applied
to this area right in here and there we
go we've applied hue and saturation and
a glow effect only to this top area
right here using compositing options and
masking